eran los controles más estrictos del
mundo contra el Kobe 19 después de casi
tres años Los viajeros que entran a
China ya no tendrán que permanecer en
cuarentena una medida esperada en el
extranjero en particular por parte de la
diáspora china pero también en el país
los estudiantes en el extranjero podrán
regresar a casa la situación ha mejorado
todos ya dieron positivo una vez así que
creo que estas política es bastante
buena
estoy bastante sorprendida cuando el
país reabrió sabía que podría haber un
día como este mis planes de viaje
pospuestos hace tres años finalmente se
harán realidad sin embargo la realidad
es bastante diferente desde el
levantamiento de la política cero covid
los contagios se han disparado con
decenas de miles de casos nuevos todos
los días la consecuencia centros médicos
desbordados y escasez de medicamentos en
las farmacias en este hospital el
personal sanitario está haciendo todo lo
posible para aumentar la capacidad del
servicio de urgencias
ahora todo nuestro sistema de Medicina
interna apoya a los departamentos de
urgencias y fiebre nuestro volumen
inicial de consultas diarias Fue de más
de 160 personas Pero ahora el número
supera las 330
china no ha publicado estadísticas de
Kobe 19 desde el domingo este brote de
contagios preocupan el extranjero según
varios estudios el levantamiento de las
restricciones podría llevar a la muerte
de alrededor de un millón de personas en
China Durante los próximos meses